uh let's ponder some more on the
government's
announcement today it's going to crack
down it says on an obesity it said that
before of course
junk food advertisements they're going
to be banned a new watershed on tv as
well as online before 9 00 pm
at shops they'll not be allowed to
display sweets and chocolates at
checkouts
at the prime minister also putting an
end he says to the buy one get one free
promotions on
high fat products as part of his new
better health campaign well let's turn
to the chef jamie oliver who joins us
now who's long campaigned on this
subject uh do you feel a sense of
vindication today jamie
uh i'm actually quite surprised um i
think
we've been working in this area for the
last five years since chapter one of the
childhood obesity strategy um
and i think what we have now is a nice
platform to really get on with business
and really start doing all the things
that matter
in supporting our most vulnerable
communities so
yeah this is about every child and of
course it goes from the schools
um to the high street and a lot of these
initiatives have been driven by the
public
you know things like pester power uh and
all the kind of sweet
kid height and at the checkouts um so i
think um
you know it's a very interesting time i
i won't deny that i'm
surprised but pleasantly surprised and
that doesn't happen so often these days
um we'll get on to some of the specific
points you make about the pest repair
the checkouts and the
the you know the buy one get one free
they had the advertising watch and all
that stuff but in terms of why the why
it's happening now
question as i suppose if you look at the
covered data
i think eight percent of critically ill
patients in
intensive care units so eight percent of
them are
morbidly obese uh compared to their
prevalence of the population at large
which is closer to three percent so
there's obviously
a correlation between being morbidly
obese and being more susceptible to
the serious parts of having covered and
that seems to be perhaps
the launch pad for this initiative yeah
look i i think often in history
um awful things and crises uh allow you
to sort of take stock
um and maybe refocus on some stuffs
some stuff that they always knew about
um like i say this strategy has been
going on for five years and it's taken
boris to sort of
pull it off the shelf and get it back
into working order
uh it's the beginning uh and he says
that in his
in his release but yeah i think it's
undoubtedly
covert 19 has amplified the emotions
it's amplified the science and it's
amplified the need
to make sure that our british children
um for
all the reasons are as fit as possible
uh
and ready to be as productive as
possible as you say at least a five year
long campaign
what why do you think previous
administration something in the theresa
may's in particular
uh were seen as having watered down some
of these measures
what was their thinking do you think
well i think in in hindsight i think
we started with mr cameron um i've
always been a political in how i work
and how i stand
um but i was one of the few if not the
only member of
sort of civvy life to be involved in the
creation of chapter one
um that was looking good it looked like
he had five years ahead of him
to do some good work and then of course
brexit sort of changed things
uh then it happened mrs may came in um
and didn't have the support from her
party in my opinion um
and now um we have got to crack on we
are in crises
um and um boris seems to be
i can't believe it but boris seems to be
the one that's uh
really kind of got a plan here but what
we need
is um not one thing or two things we
need to have a kind of more
environmental strategy
where there are many many things all
pointing the same direction
to make sure that our young kids um have
the best chance
and just just to give you kind of
clarity into why do we care and why is
it utterly important to everyone in this
country
uh no matter where they come from um if
you're a kid
um and you're from a poor background
you're over twice as likely to be
overweight or obese
we know that that tracks into teenage
years and early adulthood
we know that that has correlation with
low educational attainment
we know it means that on average you get
paid less you have more days absenteeism
cost the state more and end up dying
slightly younger
than your well-off counterpart so there
is a kind of uh
an inequality story here evening the
playing field and really about
making sure that we're putting as much
support where it's needed
on the point about young people and
young obese people it just gives a sense
of
emotionally how you feel when you hear
people as they have done down the years
and we've interviewed many of them on
this news channel who advanced the
argument that actually
it's about choice and it's especially
choice for people who can't afford
necessarily healthier food
i know we've been around that block so
many times but just give you a sense of
the frustration you feel uh when people
mount that particular argument
it's very easy to kind of get onto a
one-liner sort of slightly tabloid view
on a scenario
and a person uh we've got to just step
back
and really have a deep look and i think
you know what we've learned in the last
decade
um actually is that obesity is a normal
response to an abnormal environment
and that what we need to do is as a
whole community
and that's business that's the home and
the government we need to really
try to edit what we have and what we
consider normal
and that's everything from you know the
geekiness of reformulating products
and how clean our deck of ingredients
are on snacks or or dishes
um it's it's school lunches it's holiday
hunger like the
the marcus rashford story recently was a
holiday hunger
issue so what do we feed the kids that
are on free school lunches
um you know it's big it's wide and it
does
require a task force and the interesting
thing is not doing anything and
i think partly that's why today is a
little bit more organized and profound
and
you know i think a lot of people are
surprised how good
this is that um boris has driven this
forward uh
is you know it's it's gonna be more cost
effective
it's going to be more ethical to do this
and we're going to be more productive as
a country going forward in the next 20
years
if we can get these basics right and
yeah
and that's going to matter a lot you
know given the current state of the
economy just you you mentioned
abnormal environments i mean this is an
abnormal environment we're living
through now and people in hospitality
you don't need me to tell you i really
do find it an abnormal environment
we were talking to a campaigner an hour
or so ago and we were discussing whether
there is any early evidence in
just to make a connection between
pandemic lockdown people
not able to go out and exercise perhaps
binging
food snacking and whether there is you
know any evidence yet she said no it's
too early
anecdotally do you have any hunch as
to where it's going that you know you
presume don't you that people are
staying in there eating more and there's
an effect on obesity there
yeah i mean i think um in the months
that
roll out we'll start to see uh if people
have got healthier or not
in lockdown i mean anecdotally i think
this has been a time
for mass contemplation i think
not just eating but nourishing
has been a conversation huge online um
i i think that people have never cooked
so much
uh and we've seen huge unusual skews
in all kinds of aspects of cooking um
and i think
so so we kind of have to look at this
scenario as in
yes we have been in lockdown um you know
people realize
that good food for getting more fruit
and veg into your diet is beneficial to
the immune system the immune system
is key to being in the best shape to
deal with covered 19 if
you're unlucky enough to get it and at
the same time i think there is
social mental health issues around the
ability to turn a pile of ingredients
that can be very very cheap to get hold
of and turn it into a delicious meal
so i think anecdotally i mean we've got
one of the best
we've got one we have got one of the
best but we've got one of the biggest
cooking websites in the country
and uh our numbers are more like
christmas
um and christmas is normally our time
where
most people even the people that don't
cook cook so
in that sense it will be very
interesting to see
uh what's going on but without question
people have been baking more cooking
more
and talking more about food and and
where it comes from and how it affects
their bodies yeah
and just to bring us the full circle
back to where we started the specifics
of what
boris johnson this administration are
looking at here uh
you mentioned pester power the idea of
what happens at the checkout stopping
those promotions
you know the the tug on your on your on
your jacket from a child who sees
there's a promotion going on can i have
one of those please dad
um to some of the bands the watershed
that we're going to see for online and
tv 9 pm the cut off what's the one
that's catching your eye
the one that you think is going to make
the biggest difference online
i think the online's the wild west um i
mean i think you know most kids don't
watch telly
um and if they do it's certainly not
before six it's in the big
um highlight programs um so
we know that if you watch a full kind of
prime time
family show that within the time of that
series you've watched a whole junk food
film
um so we know that's powerful but really
for me i think the online bit
um is kind of the where the future
problems really lie
any parent that watches their kid as do
i uh with their kids
on you know screens um
it is the wild west out there i mean
we're short of quite a lot of
legislation
of what happens there and what our kids
get served and what they see
unexpectedly and what they're shared and
um
you know it's uh i think a really good
sign
that they haven't tried to control the
nuance of online they've just said
none no no and i i think
um uh i i quite like the boldness and
the clarity
um and um i i think it
it it has surprised me and and i welcome
it totally
um and then for all the other groups
that have been campaigning hard for
child health
uh you know and this gives us now a
platform to sort of get on with some
really good work
yeah just one final thought before you
answer that call you mentioned kids
plural
you've got quite a brood haven't you i'm
always curious to have people with lots
of children how they coped during
lockdown how did you find it
oh um look i think um from teenagers
that just wanted to be out with their
friends
uh to a little three-year-old that
wanted to climb up everything and paint
everything
um it was it was colorful to say the
least
um and i think like a lot of families
you know um the first six weeks were
quite trying
i found myself unexpectedly um doing
um not a live tv show but pretty much
within 16 hours every day we were
filming a cooking show that was very
much
um sort of covered lock down based about
swap ins and things you can do and how
you can be creative
with basic ingredients so that was never
expected but it kind of
kept me busy for a month but um i also
got some real quality time with my kids
and
and my wife and um and and of course i'm
grateful for that but um
what a time jamie oliver really you to
talk to you thanks for your time thanks
a lot